[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be exploring
recasting options for the one and only
Harry in Harry Potter let me start off
by saying that I thought Daniel
Radcliffe did an amazing job his role as
Harry couldn't have been more perfect at
least in my eyes and I think that he was
the best possible selection for the role
and while I feel that he was almost an
immediate to fit right from the
beginning with his performance than the
Philosopher's Stone he really leaned
into the role as he grew older proving
more and more with each film that he
truly was the ideal candidate he was
Harry Potter however with all of that
being said for today's video I wanted to
explore some casting options for the
role of Harry Daniel killed it but I was
thinking to myself which other actors do
I know that could have pulled it off
which actors could come even close to
the performance that Radcliffe gave the
inspiration for this video came from the
channel Brian
seeker who has a whole series on Harry
Potter recasting without further ado
let's jump into it candidate number one
Elijah Wood Elijah Wood is almost a
given because he is nearly identical to
Daniel Radcliffe in every way they are
around a similar height with a similar
build and their faces are remarkably
similar in a multitude of interviews
both Daniel and Elijah have expressed
they have been confused for one another
Elijah has an impressive resume with a
proven ability to act in a fantasy
setting if you didn't know already
Elijah Wood is Frodo from the iconic
Lord of the Rings films with that being
said Elijah does sound quite different
to Daniel he obviously is not British
which could be a bit of a problem but
the quality of his voice seems as though
it could be appropriate for the
character of Harry if he was able to
nail the accent I think that he would be
an amazing fit Daniel Radcliffe himself
admitted that Elijah Wood would be a
great replacement for him in an
interview when asked who should take
over his role as Harry in a film
adaptation of the cursed child Radcliffe
said the following I'm going to really
annoy him but I feel like Elijah Wood
gets recognized as me so much that he
may as well have a go at playing the
part
good enough for me candidate number two
nicholas hoult to date nicholas hoult
has an impressive acting resume if you
don't know who he is I'm sure you would
know his face in more recent years
halt plays the role of beast or Hank
McCoy in the x-men films however halt
has been acting for a while and had a
number of large roles as a child actor
perhaps most notably the role of Marcus
brewer in about a boy a film that he
co-starred in with Hugh Grant in about a
boy Holt was just 13 years old and
played the role of a somewhat tragic
young man who was down on his luck
life just really wasn't going well for
him his home life is bad his school life
was bad and well his life was pretty bad
Holt played this part extremely well
which is one of the reasons that I think
he would have been able to handle the
role of Harry Potter quite well similar
to Holt's character in about a boy
harry's formative years were not joyful
as he had to endure the constant
scrutiny of the Dursleys both characters
stuck out to me as a little bit lost in
the world and each actor played the part
remarkably well while Holtz does not
look too similar to Daniel Radcliffe I
still think that he could play a
convincing Harry bonus points to go to
halt for being born the same year as
right cliff and already having the
British accent I read in a few places
that Holt actually auditioned for the
role of Harry but was turned down I
wasn't able to confirm if this is true
or not
candidate number 3 Tom Holland I know
what you're thinking Tom Holland is far
too full of exuberance for the role of
Harry
we know Tom Holland for his recent
performances in the most recent
spider-man film as well as the Avengers
films how can such an upbeat young man
even begin to be convincing as an
oppressed little boy
he may be full of life but he's an
exceptional actor and has demonstrated
on numerous occasions that he's capable
of more genuine emotional and serious
acting if it is required of him Holland
is of similar statue to Radcliffe and
though he doesn't look particularly
similar I still think he could be
convincing as Harry similar to Radcliffe
Holland has a certain youthfulness to
him which I think would mesh well with
the role it also doesn't hurt that
Holland is also a self-professed Potter
head in an interview on BBC Radio 1 he
even said I think I might know more
about Harry Potter than JK Rowling this
is a questionable statement but I still
think that is a genuine testament to
love for the whistling world Holland is
a proud Gryffindor like Radcliffe and
the quality of his voice is actually
remarkably similar to reckless with that
being said those are some of my choices
for alternate castings for the role of
Harry Potter as I said in the beginning
Radcliffe smashed it and they couldn't
had anyone better than him but I do
think that the aforementioned actors may
have been able to handle it decently
what do you guys think of these choices
who would you cast as Harry Potter in a
world with no Daniel Radcliffe let me
know down below until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]